how I understand you there was a bit of  romance for you fell in love on the set  is that true I did that's what I heard  that's that's what yeah there's a rumor  that you fell in love on it but my  castmates don't know about it but busted  why you can plus me out that's my job my  job  what's this well I don't know what bust  me out means second  the reason I'm busting you out because  that's my job to reveal interesting  information I did I there was a boy that  yeah there was a boy and um and then I  guess the reason I liked him is that he  was very quiet he did whatever I said  let me have my way perfect things you  like we have a photograph here yeah  there we go  it's just you really bonded with this  horse didn't you it was Charlie yeah I  did so people forever have been trying  to figure out how to make you love them  and they just needed to act like a horse  [Laughter]  you